more than 100 000 Americans are
currently waiting for a second chance at
life on the organ transplant list over
600 of them live right here in Nevada an
event held tonight is meant to encourage
more nevadans to become organ donors 8
news now reporter Brian will joins us
near Buffalo and blue diamond tonight
with more Brian
yeah good evening Sasha right here
hundreds on Nevada and walked and ran to
raise awareness for organ donations to
cap off Donate Life month I spoke to one
of the participants for their reason for
walking
come on let's slow for Brianna love this
walk with her family and friends is
personal in July of 2016 I was diagnosed
with heart failure my heart was beating
at 20 when they checked and they said
that you need a heart transplant and you
have a weak that moment changed her
entire life it was very scary because I
had no idea what that was I was 11 at
the time I just come back from you know
it's a summer's worth of riding roller
coasters and all of a sudden you're
being told that that's the end luckily
she is here today thanks to an organ
donation and her and others are walking
in this hope glows event to encourage
others to become organ donors the Nevada
donor Network says there's a large need
especially among minority communities
and each donation can have a huge impact
one organ donor can save the life of
eight others and one teacher donor can
heal the life of more than 75 people and
stories like Rihanna loves are numerous
among this crowd she's looking forward
to graduating high school and going to
UNLV next year her goal is to inspire
more organ donors I'm living proof that
it's successful that it works and that
I'm not afraid to do anything and I'm
I'm just gonna live life to the fullest
now heart transplants don't last a
lifetime and Brianna will need another
one in about 30 years or when she's in
her 40s you can find out more
information about organ donations at our
website at 8newsnow.com reporting live
at Exploration Peak Park Brian will 8
News Now